And I think it's a good example
of sometimes, you can find a real gap
in the market in something
that is like very niche.
Like it would never become
a billion dollar company, obviously.
Lior Grossman, thank you
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you very, very much for being here.
All the way from sunny California
to the dark and stormy Tel Aviv.
But, you know, it's interchanging
and both places have wonderful weather.
Lior, an expert in open-source.
I think you founded like
five or six companies in this world.
And it's unbelievable
not all of them in this world.
But I know that that's
what OpenBase is about
and some of the others like
Wikiwand and something like that.
But I would love to first hear
about your journey here,
about who you are
starting all the way back
when you built your own computer
within your car.
And I have to say
that when I buy a car,
the first thing that I look at
is the multimedia screen
and you actually built one for yourself.
So, tell me about that.
Right.
That's a crazy story, actually.
So, my first car,
it was a blue Peugeot 106.
Kind of like, I think it was like
the '97 model.
And back then in the days, like,
it's a really old car.
It didn't have like a multimedia system.
And being the computer geek that I am,
I decided to do something about it.
So, I ended up
actually building a personal computer
that sits in the trunk of the car.
It's connected like through cables
all of it run all through the car.
And I ordered a touch screen.
Touchscreen was like a thing
like back then,
like in the early 2000.
So, I actually had to order one
from eBay.
Got it all the way,
built it into the dashboard of the car.
And basically every time
I would start the car,
it would start a personal computer
sitting in the trunk.
It would have multimedia,
it would have music,
it would have Wi-Fi, everything.
This was kind of
a very crazy hobby project
I would say.
Unbelievable.
`I love those types of projects.
It's really amazing.
Tell me a little bit
about your startup journey.
I know that you were a team leader
in one of the elite units in the IDF.
And then you go and you go
and you built a massive
portfolio of companies,
each of them in a different space.
All of them making a huge impact.
Walk me through some of them
before we reach Openbase
and the open-source industry.
Sure. So, I have been
I would say a late bloomer
as entrepreneur.
So, I think, you know,
I would say my focus
has been mostly
on entrepreneurship
for the past decade or so.
But you know,
God, I'm old.
So
basically, I got into entrepreneurship
by building my own
software development firm.
So, around 2007,
I started my own
software development firm.
It was called Openbase.
I've been working
with wonderful, wonderful clients,
most of them small startups,
and I helped them get to market
with their products.
And this has revealed the world
of entrepreneurship to me
in the world of startups
and how fascinating it is.
And the kind of like challenges
they had around product,
around go to market,
around uncertainty.
And that's how I kind of like
got enchanted and
got into this world of startups.
So, I would say in the past decade,
I've probably build
in one capacity or another,
probably build a dozen products
at the very least, maybe even more.
Some of them were,
kind of like, you know,
entirely bootstrap.
Most of them, honestly,
were it's complete failure.
I think that's part of the process.
Some of them were more successful.
A couple of them more actually
have came to become profitable businesses
that are still active
and they generate revenue.
They have a lot of happy users
and I'm very proud.
But I think it's all part of the journey,
kind of like being able to fail
and learn from your mistake
and kind of like not repeat
the same mistake twice
and improve as an entrepreneur over time.
So, previously, I build BookAuthority,
which is
basically a recommendation website
for books, if you will.
It's like good Goodreads.
But we base our recommendations
based on experts, like
people like Elon Musk,
people like Jeff Bezos,
recommending books.
And we highlight
the most recommended books
on our platform.
So, this BookAuthority
has quite a lot of traction.
I think almost a million users a month,
a lot of recommendations,
a lot of books sold.
Yeah. That's a great, great,
great example of like dogfooding.
Because I set out
to build BookAuthority
to solve my own problem.
I was looking for great books to read
and I was sifting through
like articles on Forbes and Ink.
Eventually, I couldn't find
the most recommend the books
so, I ended up building this database.
I love it.
That came to be BookAuthority.
I just love it.
That type of stuff inspires me
just like what you did
with the PC for the car.
My father was at Google.
He didn't never had time
to listen to articles
and he had a pipeline of hundreds,
if not thousands of articles.
And he said,
"Why can't the phone read those out to me
with the push of a button
or by with the assistant??
So, he developed an app within Google
that is now used
by a lot of people around the world
that reads articles for busy people
as they're driving
as if it's a podcast.
But I digress.
But that is the exact type
of entrepreneurship and innovation
that really inspires me.
Tell me a little bit
about Wikiwand and Darkness,
because those are also
two fascinating ventures
that I'd love to learn more about.
Yeah. So, Darkness
is an interesting example of,
I would say, a gap in the market.
So, nowadays,
you would notice like,
today a lot of websites
and apps offer dark themes.
So, you would have it like on YouTube
and you would have it
in Facebook more recently.
And now I think, you know,
you have it in Google
in beta, basically your search base
in a dark theme.
But I started Darkness
a few years ago.
And at this time,
I knew how much I love dark themes.
And then kind of like
from my other products,
I kind of realized a lot
of other people around the world
love the concept of like
browsing websites through dark themes.
People sometimes are like night owls.
They like working at night.
A bright screen is like very glaring.
It's not fun to use. And also you have
this coolness factor
about like working with a dark theme.
So, I decided to build Darkness.
Darkness is an extension
for chrome that allows you
to convert, to transform,
I think about like 20 websites
to be dark themed.
And we support like Google, Facebook,
YouTube, like many other websites.
And we had quite a lot of success.
We were actually featured
in Chrome web store,
we got a lot of downloads.
The product itself is
kind of dual in depth like
it is an open source product
so, you can use
the open source version,
download it for free,
get like all the features,
get it installed on your computer.
Or you can download it from
a Chrome web store,
where it's a freemium product
in a way
where you have the basic features said.
But if you want to get like
the full possibility,
basically get access to like
20 different websites,
seven different themes, you pay.
Basically, that's like a micropayment.
We don't charge $99 an hour
for a chrome extension, obviously.
But the nice thing about it
is that we had tens of thousands
of paying customers for Darkness.
So, it has become quite a success.
And I think it's a good example
of sometimes, you can find
a real gap in the market
in something that is like very niche.
Like it would never become
a billion dollar company, obviously.
But I ended up like
solving my own problem,
and on the way,
solving the problem
for hundreds of thousands
of other people around the world.
Unbelievable.
I remember when one of the developers,
and I was also at 8200,
and I remember the day
that one of our developers,
his name is Gilad,
he brought it into the unit
dark theme for a lot of the applications.
And I remember everybody
was going crazy.
For some reason,
engineers and developers love dark themes.
Now it's actually become a common.
I think that iOS launched
their dark themes recently.
But you know,
I love that idea
of solving your own problems again.
And what about a Wikiwand?
What is that about?
So, Wikiwand.
I started Wikiwand back in,
it was 2013, I started it
with Saar Wilf, which is an amazing,
amazing serial investor,
one of the best angel investors
in Israel, I think.
And the idea behind Wikiwand was that,
again, there is this huge gap
in the market.
So, you have Wikipedia.
Wikipedia is one of the top 10 websites
on the Internet in terms of like usage.
You have like hundreds of like
tens of billions of users
using Wikipedia all the time.
And the funny thing about Wikipedia
is that it's so frequently used,
but it is a product
that hasn't evolved
for the past decade.
It hasn't evolved at all
in terms of like the user experience,
the usability, the feature set,
it's still the same old Wikipedia.
And we're all like
very frustrated by that.
So, we decided to basically
we build Wikipedia for the modern user.
So, like, you would get the same content
that you get on Wikipedia,
but with better readability,
with better search, better discovery,
power features, customized ability.
One of the things we had early on,
it wasn't that popular back in the days,
but we had a dark theme.
So, you could customize your interface
and select the dark theme for Wikiwand.
And we ended up growing
really, really fast.
Wikiwand, we ended up winning
the 2015 Webby Award
for the best user experience
on the Internet.
Yeah, yeah. The Webby Award.
And yeah, this is like
thanks to the amazing team.
Like we have Saar and Ilan,
and Tomer, our designer like
the team, we're a small team,
kind of like doing amazing work
around like buildings product.
It has become a huge success.
We have over 10 million people
using Wikiwand every month
right now, it's a profitable business.
Yeah, it's a pleasure to use ,honestly,
more that I'm proud, like, you know,
proud with the correction.
I'm proud that it's
a product that I enjoy use
and we know so many
people enjoy using Wikiwand.
Wow. Lior,
we'll get to the Y Combinator experience
and open base and how you're solving
a pretty big problem for developers
with so many open -source opportunities.
But I have to gauge your passion
for solving problems with product.
Sometimes they're niche,
sometimes they're not so niche.
But what is it about solving problems
with great people
that really gets you excited?
Because you've done it so much.
You've been successful
in almost all of them,
which is incredible.
But why do you do that?
Why not just go start
a billion dollar company 10 years ago?
I think it's about like in a way,
it's a lot about
the journey of entrepreneur.
And I wouldn't say,
you know, I build a lot of failures.
And like there's always this
I would say survivorship bias
where like you learn about the successes.
But I could fill up
an episode of an hour
about all the products that I built
and were never successful.
And I think it's important
for other entrepreneurs to hear about it
because it's not always
like sunny and roses.
And a lot of things that I build
were like downright failure.
And some of them more like, you know,
a mild success, and some of them
like were a bigger success.
And that's part of the journey.
But I'm kind of like digressing.
I think for me,
building products or like creating
is part of like my invocation.
This is not a job.
This is not even a hobby.
I recall even when I was younger,
before I got into programming,
before I got into entrepreneurship,
before I had the skills,
I always loved creating things.
Whether like drawing schemes
or coming up with inventions
and stuff like that.
So, for me, that's not even a choice.
I think that's just the way I work.
I don't see myself doing anything else by
but creating,
but building products.
I just love that.
So, Y Combinator, Openbase.
Solving a problem
in the open-source space.
Before we even talk about open space,
what is open-source?
What is open-source
and why is it a growing field today?
So, open-source is kind of like
an amazing phenomenon,
I would say, in software development.
So, I've been developing software
for a while,
probably since I was 10.
And software development
like two decades ago
was very different from today.
So, two decades ago,
if you were to develop
a complicated rich piece of software,
you had to develop
every little piece yourself.
Right.
And that means like you have a product,
you have a tooltip,
you have a, so like a dialogue
that you want to display,
you want to handle text manipulation.
All of these as a developer,
as a company,
you had to develop yourself.
And the open-source movement
was kind of revolutionary.
And that other developers,
developers around the world
started working collaboratively
with other developers
and sharing their source code,
what they've built with other developers.
So, now as a developer,
you can tap to the collective knowledge,
collective power of millions
of other developers around the world.
And when you build software nowadays,
actually the statistics are astounding.
So, more than 50% of a modern app,
modern product, modern website
is comprised of open-source code.
And less than 50% is actually built by
that person or company.
So, I think the wonderful thing
about open-source
is that it allows company
to focus on their core competency
on their product, while utilizing
the collective power of open-source,
so, they don't have
to reinvent the wheel.
They don't have
to keep like building this dialogue
and this text parsing,
and this like, those accounting functions,
because other people have done this.
So, in a way they're standing
on the shoulders of giants.
That makes a lot of sense.
So, what is the opportunity
that you realize in that gap?
Because as a developer,
when I write and,
I'm actually surprised that
it's not more than 50%,
because when I go into
write an application,
if it's a relatively simple application,
I think maybe 80% of the code
that I end up having is importing
a code that much smarter
and more intelligent engineers built.
But what what is the gap
that you found in the market
that led you to start Openbase
and have that great opportunity?
So, I found myself
and developers around me
spending so much time researching
and evaluating open-source packages.
And the thing is,
it wasn't an issue a decade ago
because you only had
a couple of packages to do every test.
Whereas like today,
if you look at the JavaScript ecosystem,
you have almost 1.5 million packages
to choose from.
And that is basically a jungle.
It's very hard to choose
the right package.
And even if you know specifically
what you're looking for,
you're looking for a specific task
to accomplish, you have hundreds
of competing packages to choose from.
And this begs the question like,
how do you choose the right one?
So, I was spending
a significant amount of time
each and every time
I was looking for an open-
source component.
And then speaking to other developers,
I found it like, you know,
I'm not the only crazy one.
In general, developers
spend a lot of time
sifting through packages
and trying to find the best one for them.
Right.
And that's why I set out
to build Openbase, that was
May of 2019 last year.
And it's been quite a wild ride since then.
I can't even imagine.
In a few sentences, tell me about
the Y Combinator experience?
Because that by itself
is one of the most
sought after experiences
of any entrepreneur.
Yeah. So, the Y Combinator experience
has been amazing.
So, we were actually the summer
2020 batch of Y Combinator.
That has been
the first fully remote batch of YCE.
I think the amazing thing about it
was seeing so many international founders
from all around the world like,
you know, entrepreneurs are
entrepreneurs, like the same people
kind of like struggle
with the same problems,
trying to achieve the same objective.
So, this was an amazing experience.
We had an amazing set of partners in YC
So like, help work us
through some of the growing challenges
of Openbase.
I think they managed
to pull off something like this,
like this was the first remote batch
and they managed to execute it
so well, you know.
Starting from like the office hours
and the day to day
and the kind of people
they kind of brought on
to talk to the startups.
And the demo day itself.
Demo day was quite a feat,
because, like,
you have so many startups pitching,
thousands of investors live on Zoom.
Getting all of that to work flawlessly,
that is like quite a feat.
So, this has been
once in a lifetime experience.
That's for sure.
I can't even imagine.
What are some, perhaps,
your two cents from a great summer
that you would take with you
moving forward with it,
or advice that you would give
to young entrepreneurs?
So, I think, you know,
maybe paradoxically,
my biggest advice will like take away
from YC is, for example,
I was speaking with some YC partners,
I was speaking with one partner
and getting this advice,
and I was speaking
to the other partner
and getting this other advice.
And both of them are
like you know, super qualified,
highly successful entrepreneurs
with a lot of experience
that has seen like hundreds of startups.
So, my advice would be,
take any advice with a grain of salt.
Because I think the further you go down
the rabbit hole of,
like building a startup,
the more specific your startup becomes.
So, you need to take any advice
within the right context.
And I think generic advices
are great when you get started.
But the more you go in,
the more you have baggage,
the more you have specific circumstances,
you would need a very specific advice.
So, what I did
is kind of I utilized the advice
to give me perspective.
And it was always like,
great, because that was like
a fresh perspective
or like a way of seeing things
that I've never thought about before.
But it doesn't mean that
I take this advice at par value.
It doesn't mean that, like,
you know, this person tells me,
yeah, I think that this could work,
this could not,
I'm not taking it at par value,
but whether I'm synthesizing
all the data that I get,
I sort of like build the map
of the full gamut
of all the possibilities
of the things that I can do.
And I think this is something
that YC was really useful.
Kind of like showing
the full gamut of things
that you can do at each stage.
But then, as the CEO,
it's my own responsibility
to come up with a choice.
You cannot outsource your choices
and your decisions to someone else
that gives you advice.
100%.
Lior, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
This was great.
Before we leave, I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Wow. So, that's a great question.
I would say, first is,
I would say I'm ambitious.
So, I've always been
and I think, you know, it's part
of the thrill for me
to pursue big goals.
The other thing is resourceful.
Because I'm always like even through,
like, tough times,
even when things are hard,
I'm trying to find the right path
moving forward instead of, like,
regretting or looking back.
Right.
And I think that's like
a very helpful thing as entrepreneur.
And the last but not least,
I would say creator.
Because that's my passion.
That's my invocation.
That's what I love doing.
I love creating.
Lior, this was great.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for the inspiration.
Best of luck with Openbase.
I can't wait to use it myself
as an engineer.
But thank you very much.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.
Of course.